INDUSTRY FIRST, AMERICAN WORKERS
AND IT'S ABOUT TIME.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING US NOW FROM HERE IN
SECRETARY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU, HOW ARE
YOU?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
>> Laura: I WILL QUIZ YOU ON
TRADE, BUT I WILL GET INTO
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE FACT
THAT WE HAD TO SHUT DOWN OVER
HER BUT NOW IT'S ON TO THIS
FEBRUARY 8TH DEADLINE FOR
PASSING SOME KIND OF DACA.
NOW, LINDSEY GRAHAM, JEFF FLAKE,
DICK DURBIN, THEY WANT A PLAN
THAT THEY TRIED TO FORCE ON THE
PRESIDENT THAT A SENIOR HOUSE
BROUGHT UP FOR A VOTE.
>> IT WOULD NEVER BE BROUGHT UP
IS WHAT I'M HEARING AS WELL.
IF IT EVER GOT TO THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK, IT WOULD NEVER
WE ALSO THE 55 MINUTE SHOW AT
THE BIPARTISAN-BICAMERAL MEETING
IN THE CABINET ROOM.
THEY SAID FOR MY NATIONAL
SECURITY PACKAGE, I NEED FOUR
THINGS COME UP BORDER SECURITY
WITH A WALL, ENDING CHAIN
MIGRATION, ENDING THE VISA
LOTTERY, AND A LASTING SOLUTION
FOR DACA.
>> Laura: LISTEN OVER THE
WEEKEND, WE GAVE THEM MONEY FOR
A STINKING WALL.
HE DIDN'T REALLY CARE ABOUT
--DASH WE GAVE HIM THAT.
WHAT'S THE REAL TRUTH ABOUT
THAT.
>> NOT TRUE.
IN FACT THE GRAHAM DURBIN
BUILDING COVER ANYTHING THAT
THEY WANTED, IN FACT IT MADE THE
SITUATION MUCH      MUCH, MUCH W
SITUATION MUCH      MUCH, MUCH R
SITUATION MUCH      MUCH, MUCH E
SITUATION MUCH      MUCH, MUCH .
THEY RECEIVED UPWARDS OF
8 MILLION PEOPLE.
IT DID NOT FUND THE WALL, AND IT
KEPT CHAIN MIGRATION GOING.
GROW QUICKLY, THE MIGRATION
POLICIES SAYS WE HAVE ABOUT
3.25 MILLION PEOPLE HERE THAT
ARE DREAMERS AND DOCK OF
RECIPIENTS THAT WOULD'VE
PARENTS TO RECEIVE THREE YEARS
IN THE COUNTRY AND THEN ONCE
THEY WERE ALL HERE, THEY WILL
GIVE THEM THE RIGHT FOR CHAIN
MIGRATION AS WELL.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT 8 MILLION,
10 MILLION PEOPLE BY THE TIME
IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE WAS
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
WISCONSIN, OHIO, PENNSYLVANIA,
BUT IT WAS ABOUT 80,000 VOTES TO
GIVE HIM THE ELECTION.
YOU'RE TALKING MILLIONS OF NEW
VOTING AMERICAN CITIZENS, MANY
OF THEM PROBABLY BEHOLDEN TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
WHAT IS THAT MEAN FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> IF YOU REMEMBER, WHAT
RONALD REAGAN ACTUALLY DID GET
INTO SEE, I DON'T THINK HE GOT
30% OF THE FOLKS THAT CAME HERE
THROUGH THE AMNESTY PACKAGE
OPPOSED TO THIS PACKAGE.
GRAHAM AND DURBIN ARE BOTH
NEGOTIATING.
THEY BROUGHT IT TO THE
PRESIDENT, PROMISED HIM HE WOULD
GET EVERYTHING HE WANTED, AND
THE BORDER PIECE AND WALL PEAS,
DHS DID A STUDY AND SAID WE NEED
NOT ONE BUT $18 BILLION FOR THE
BALL.
THIS WAS LESS THAN ONE-TENTH OF
$1.6 BILLION FOR THE WALL.
IT DIDN'T FUND A THING.
GRAHAM AND DURBIN KNOW IT, AND
NOW THEY ARE GOING OFF AND
EVERYONE SEES THEM FOR WHAT THEY
ARE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY A
SOUND BITE FOR YOU.
WE WILL GET BACK TO LINDSEY
GRAHAM BECAUSE HE'S DRIVING THE
BUS ON THIS.
I WANT TO TALK MORE ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE BLAMING STEPHEN MILLER.
THAT'S THEIR NEW TARGET.
FIRST IT WAS BANNON AND THEN IT
GOES TO THE LIST AND OUT STEPHEN
MILLER.
LET'S WATCH.
>> STEPHEN MILLER IS THE
REASONED THAT THE PRESIDENT
BACKED AWAY FROM THAT DECISION.
>> THEY WILL NOT GET THEREBY
ALLOWING ESSENTIALLY STEPHEN
MILLER AND TOM COTTON TO CHARGE
ALL THE POLICIES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THE REASON WE YANK THESE
THINGS BACK IS BECAUSE
MR. MILLER HAS NEVER BEEN IN THE
MAINSTREAM SENATE.
>> Laura: TRUMP ROCKS THE
BASEBALL CAP.
I'M SORRY.
DOESN'T WORK FOR GRAHAM.
NOW STEPHEN MILLER IS THE BIG
BOGEYMAN AND SHIFTING.
IT STEPHEN MILLER RUNNING POLICY
AND ALL THE IMMIGRATION POLICY?
OTHER THING THEY ARE SAYING.
>> Laura: LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS
SAID THIS REPEATEDLY ABOUT
MILLER, ABOUT COTS AND COME
ABOUT PURDUE, HE'S ATTACKING ALL
OF THEM.
IF YOU MINUTES, I WILL EXPLAIN
WHAT THEY ARE ATTACKING ME.
>> I KNOW STEPHEN MILLER VERY
WELL AND I WORK WITH HIM NOW FOR
A GOOD THREE MONTHS.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME TOGETHER.
THEY SERVE AT THE PLEASURE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAD TO EXECUTE WITH THE
PRESIDENT WANTS DONE.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN,
IT'S NOT STEPHEN MILLER'S PLAN.
LINDSEY GRAHAM KNOWS THAT, AND
THERE'S NO REASON FOR HIM TO
CALL OUT.
THERE IS NO DAYLIGHT BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMP AND STEPHEN MILLER
ON IMMIGRATION.
NEITHER IS THERE ANY DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN DICK DURBIN AND LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
>> Laura: WHY DOES LINDSEY
GRAHAM GET TO GO ON TELEVISION
AND CLAIM THERE'S A BIPARTISAN
DEAL, BUT THE PRESIDENT REJECTED
IT WHEN IT'S GRAHAM AND FLAKE.
AND THEN YOU THROW ON SUSAN
COLLINS.
AGAIN, I'M SURE THEY'RE ALL
REALLY NICE PEOPLE, THEY DO NOT
TRACK THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM ON
IMMIGRATION.
THAT HARVARD HARRIS POLL SHOWS
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
IMMIGRATION LEVELS, EVEN LEGAL
IMMIGRATION LEVELS.
THE PRESIDENT IS SQUARELY IN THE
MAINSTREAM.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS A RADICAL
FANATIC ON AMNESTY.
HE HAS BEEN FOR MORE THAN 20
YEARS.
I'M NOT BEING HARSH HERE.
>> A QUICK ANTIDOTE.
HE IS ON THE FRINGE ON THIS.
THE POLLS SHOW IT.
I WAS IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
AND FROM THERE PURITY WAS MY
SENATOR  .
AT OUR STATE CONVENTION, 2,000
REPUBLICANS BOOING LINDSEY
GRAHAM FOR HIS STANCE ON
IMMIGRATION BECAUSE HE WANTS
OPEN BORDERS AND AMNESTY.
HE ALWAYS HAS, AND HITS HIS HEAD
RIGHT TO HAVE A DECISION.
DON'T PRETEND AS THOUGH YOU HAD
TO HAVE A MEETING OF THE MINDS
OF DICK DURBIN AND YOU GAVE UP
SOMETHING TO GET SOMETHING.
YOU GUYS, DICK DURBIN AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND JEFF FLAKE,